if someone doesn't support me it makes
me feel really bad I've worked my
ass off to get to where I am and
if they don't I'm like you don't care
about me you're not going to support my
dreams and my career and everything what
dreams does a woman with a neck tattoo
have am I crazy like what what dreams
down and down like what's your business
I do nails nails okay I've been doing it
for like a little over 2 and a half
years okay nice being a nail
tech really like the way these women
talk you think they're like serial
entrepreneurs what's your dream to do
nails like can't you just do your own
and your
friends I told when you say support what
do you mean um like if I show you my
work and you're like oh it's like it's
cool or if they don't
like how interested do you want men to
be in
Nails you know what I mean like I mean
how interested are you in like watches
or like a shoe collection like it's cool
but what up guys welcome to the just
perly things YouTube channel and welcome
to my reaction series today I'm going to
be reacting to boss babe can't accept
this fact about men this is from the
whatever podcast I was on this podcast a
couple of months ago uh let's play the
video I I could agree if someone doesn't
support me it makes me feel really bad
I've worked my ass off to get to
where I am and if they don't I'm like
you don't care about me you're not going
to support my dreams and my career and
everything but I'm going to support you
with everything you do yeah but if I
don't get the same back I'm not going to
with you anymore like you just what
dreams does a woman with a neck tattoo
have am I crazy like what what dreams
down and down like with my feelings
towards you if you don't what's your
business I do nails nails okay I've been
doing it for like a little over 2 and a
half years okay nice got my clientele
all that so you would be upset if uh
your partner didn't uh support you in in
terms of your business yeah okay being a
nail tech really like the way these
women talk you think they're like serial
entrepreneurs what's your dream to do
nails like can you just do your own and
your friends if I told when you say
support what do you mean um if they
don't like if I show you my work and
you're like oh it's like it's cool or if
they don't like how interested do you
want men to be in Nails you know what I
mean like I mean how interested are you
in like watches or like a shoe
collection like it's cool but you had a
really good day of work and you're
really excited about it and like you're
proud of yourself if they're not proud
of you then I don't think that's a good
thing can I add yeah sure I also so it's
like not my business it's my sister's
she does like events in town I was
talking about it I think before we
started the podcast they're like flea
markets in town and I feel like I I
usually like invite my my close friends
and stuff and if I was in a relationship
and I invited the person and they didn't
come I feel like they say like too much
I already know but I would I probably
wouldn't like them as much if they like
didn't come and support me
mhm wait so and you just going back to
you so you said that you'd want to tell
your partner about like a good day at
work so I mean no offense or anything
but what is a good day at work doing
nails if I I personally like the work
that I did I okay like cuz is there an
artistic component okay I can see the
designs could be really pretty or I had
a really good conversation King what
would you say to a girl like if she said
I had a good day at work like what I
don't I'm just trying to figure out what
she expects them guys to say I don't
understand like well cuz she's saying I
want the guy to support me with her like
nail business so if she says I have a
good day at work what do you say okay
that's I don't know I'm happy for you it
wouldn't be enough cuz she's saying it's
not enough
support guys okay his answer was exactly
what I thought guys don't like they
don't care
someone cuz I built a lot of bonds with
my clients and I become friends with
them a lot of my really close friends
now are because I met them by working
and they just make an appointment with
me and then I A lot of times I become
their friend because of the connection
we grow sure but like a lot I've like
shown guys like my work and they're like
they just either ignore that I I'll show
them a picture what they kind of ignore
it it's suppos like over text um and
they just don't really say anything or
they like I'm God I'm so proud of you
like you're doing really well um
especially like I'm 19 and I have my own
business and thank you and if they're
not supportive of that okay when women
say they have this like business right
it's always like a a nail like it's
always something where there's no
employees it's just them like doing only
fans or like nails like bit misleading
just doesn't think they're supportive of
my career a lot of guys think it's
either really cool or really
stupid yeah I mean what guy what guys
would think it's that cool like what
what guys are going to are going to
think that nails or that I mean gay men
might you know what I mean like I think
when you're in a relationship with
someone you should certainly be
supportive of them I think part of that
might be related to what it might be
related to though is
that men don't really care about a
woman's career m in just let me clarify
a bit it doesn't make you more
attractive to us if you have a career or
you're successful or you're ambitious
did you say why no I I was just saying
okay oh okay yeah just yeah so I think
for for most men like we like cuz you
might be an outlier but most women don't
share their their resources with men the
same way that men share their resources
with women I know a lot of you are in
college so it's like what you talking
about Brian but like you're probably
finances to you guys probably are not
really high on the totem pole yet
because most of the guys are probably
interacting with are in college they're
not in a career yet but as you you do
start to get a bit older um you know you
hear a lot about women like men with
high status so if that could be through
a job if they're an athlete musician
actor something like that whereas men we
do not care at we really care nothing at
all about a woman's status whereas women
care if a man has status that is can be
very
attractive it's also kind of hated upon
though like I know a lot of women who
end up with men who I guess would be
considered like lower status or not paid
as much it gets more disrespected than
if it was actually just a man of a
higher status with a woman of a lower
status I feel like that's more unusual I
feel like a lot of people yeah like
trophy yeah like the trophy wife trophy
is super common but you don't really see
the other way I feel like it's kind of
stigmatized I think it's going to be a
new thing I think it's going to be
really common older women over the age
of 35 dating 20-some year old men yes
you think it's stigmatized for a woman
to be with be with a man who's yeah like
leing less than her or if you even go on
like the internet and you just see like
these really famous influencers with
their husbands who just are in the
background it's like constantly in the
comments it's like why is she with him
what is she doing like he's like just
doing this and that it's but if you see
like a very like Ronaldo or something
you wouldn't question
why he had a girlfriend he's back's he's
back he's watching round two uh sorry go
ahead oh like first like a famous
celebrity or something like that if it
was a male you wouldn't you wouldn't bad
an ey if they had like a really
attractive younger person who wasn't
even a celebrity yeah yeah I would say
though overwhelmingly like a lot of did
you want to come in on this it looked
like you were okay it looked like it
seems like for women who are high
status there are definitely women that
will date down but the thing is is as a
woman as you start increasing your
status and as you start making more
money your pool of potential Partners
tends to shrink because most
women don't want to date a guy who's
lower status than them or whose uh
earning potential is lower than them now
again true you guys are in college so
like you haven't probably played too
much or wrestled too much with these
sort of Dynamics but and I know you're
an outlier apparently but um I'd say so
yeah most most women and if you I think
they've done polls on this like most
women and you can also do it with uh
education attainment most women would
want to date a man who is is at least as
or more educated than she is I think as
might be I don't
know so if she has a bachelor she wants
a guy who has a bachelor she has a
masters I don't know if they they did it
for uh you know what interesting the
pulling for younger women on what they
rate desirable when they're younger it
tends to be something like a nice car or
like um a nice restaurant stuff like
that where when they're older it tends
to be more like like
pensions um like um a house like
long-term stuff grad student like people
who have a graduate level degrees but um
postgrad whatever it's called Uh so yeah
I I feel like with that it's just like
finding a partner like you're finding an
equal like you want to have someone who
has kind of the same Ed like when you
were saying with education like you want
someone with the same education as you
it's more of just see seeing someone as
like an equal instead of like maybe
having to like try and explain things to
him that he wouldn't understand and
that's not saying like you both have to
have like engineering degrees in order
for that to happen like it can
definitely be where maybe like she is
some like boss businesswoman but he's
out like doing like I don't know maybe
he's just like doing something like a
little little bit it's always like a
personal trainer or musician whenever
it's like the women are high earning
it's always personal trainer musician or
some sort of like exciting job where
they're good-looking I don't really I
can't think of any examples but it
doesn't mean like I feel like it's not
it's not so much as something that needs
to be put down on paper it's kind of
like an everyday kind of thing like she
wants to be able to talk to him and not
feel like she's talking to someone that
isn't matching her like mentally if that
makes sense I think men also kind of
feel like from what I've talked to I
feel like I've met more men who like are
more comfortable or prefer taking that
like bread winner position like a lot of
guys I've talked to like actually want
it's mostly it's like 20% roughly are
stay-at-home moms and then half of the
population it's 5050 but the man still
does the majority of the bills typically
to engage in that I think for a woman
it's more because only recently like
like when the past 100 years one have
kind of gotten the rights to do whatever
so it's kind of always trying to work up
on an even playing field versus I think
a lot of men still kind of just want to
not all of them but a lot do I mean
who's going to watch the kids like who
who what if yeah do you find a lot of
women want to fall into the role of you
know housewife I've actually met quite a
few who like actually want to do that
especially more like religious people
but mhm it's still pretty common I'd say
did anybody else want to come in on this
oh sorry did did you have more I was
just saying in University it's kind of
biased cuz all the girls here are
pursuing like a higher education so you
wouldn't really find that yeah and
obviously like sometimes like girls joke
about it like oh it would be so nice to
just marry rich and then you don't have
to worry about anything but I like how
she says they want to marry rich and
they don't say stay home with the kids
so many times staying home is associated
with being rich when a lot of housewives
are actually they just live a very
frugal LIF style and don't spend on
extravagant things and that's why Kevin
Samuels would always ask do you want to
stay home with the kids women always
want to be stay-at-home moms in Upper to
middle class neighborhoods that is
expensive that lifestyle is expensive
they don't want to move into the country
and be at stay-at-home mothers never go
on vacation that's not what they see
they want it to be their kids are in the
best schools they want to travel that
would be nice it would be nice that
would be nice it's it's the dream but
obviously like every time like I say
personally like I mean it as a joke like
I have my own aspirations mhm what are
your aspirations well I mean what you
what you say again I'm Undeclared oh
okay like I don't have any at the moment
but like I do
want to have something of my own like if
I were to get into a relationship like I
and see that's programming she's been
taught she always has to have a backup
plan always always always guys this has
been 50 years of this personally would
not want to just like live off of
everything that he's doing and just have
like if I want to go grocery shopping
hey can I get some money to go grocery
shopping like that's not what I want to
do I just want to come in on this really
quick so it's kind of interesting
because like you have so traditionally
you would have the man providing and it
was more traditional so he'd be the head
of the household he'd be the lead the
leader so to speak and it's interesting
to me that women so you could say that
women were submissive to their husbands
wives were submissive to their husbands
but you've traded that by being
submissive to an employer you now
instead of being submissive to your
husband you are now submissive to an
employer and your employer is going to
ask I would say much more of you than
what a husband well I mean wouldn't you
also be like submissive to an employer
yeah I mean we're all submissive to
something no but I'm saying like
traditionally if the man if if you were
say a stay-at-home you didn't have to go
out in labor you didn't have to go out
and work work you would you would only
be submissive to a husband and the kids
and the cleaning and the cooking and
yeah well I don't think I don't think
women should be submissive to their
children well they do have to like do
everything for them okay fair but well
you're I I think as a as a mother you
have author you're in a position of
authority over your children yeah
hopefully get yeah you know and Brian
brings up a lot of good points so many
times chicks like the thought of
listening to their it's so backward
words because we put money at the top of
everything instead of listening to your
husband who gives you children we listen
to an employer who gives us money and I
understand it's 2023 people still have
to work but why can't women work inside
the home I mean there's a million
stay-at-home working jobs laptop jobs
that you can do but let me know what you
guys think at the comments what a what a
show like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time